what's up everyone welcome back to my
channel Richard on data if you're new
here my name is Richard and this is the
channel where we talk about data data
science statistics and programming
subscribe for all kinds of content just
like this and hit the notification bell
so YouTube notifies you whenever I
upload a video I've done videos on where
the are vs. Python debate stands in 2020
as well as on the Julia programming
language if you missed those videos the
links will be in the description I've
also done a video on why it's important
to use or at least be familiar with an
open-source programming language in the
year 2020 having set all of that if
you're looking for a job you're probably
gonna end up seeing SAS in a number of
descriptions so I thought it'd be worth
answering the question of is it still
worth learning SAS in the year 2020 if
you're a current or aspiring data
scientist who's not familiar with it yet
to answer that question we're going to
look at a few things here so everybody
knows that the undisputed juggernauts of
the data science world are our own
Python then there's speculation that in
about three to five years from now Julia
might start giving our own Python a run
for their money
but we're going to look at how many
people are really using SAS right now in
what industries are they using it then
we're gonna come and look at the
relative capabilities of SAS compared to
these other languages speculate on what
the future holds for SAS and then answer
that question about is it worth your
investment to learn first a little bit
of history on SAS SAS was developed at
the North Carolina State University
between the years of 1966 and 1976 and
since then it's had a ton of different
releases its proprietary software
meaning it's not open source so the
price of a SAS license can vary
substantially based on a number of
factors probably most importantly being
is it for a single user or is it for an
enterprise business
so most SAS usage out there is in big
business where the cost of a SAS license
is just a drop in the bucket however
there is a SAS university edition which
is free and the link to that will be in
description next let's get a feel for
how popular sass is and how many people
are using it compared to our and Python
so when I did my R versus Python video
back in January I looked at the taya B
index which is a very common metric for
assessing the popularity of programming
languages at a given point in time and
at that time Python was the number three
most popular programming language based
on that list and R was at number 18 one
month later
Python is still number three and R is at
number thirteen although it is important
to see that after like number six a lot
of these are super close to each other
and naturally some of these are very
apples to oranges comparisons based on
this index Python has nine point three
four five percent of search traffic
while R has one point zero zero five
percent of search traffic now by
comparison sass is in the number twenty
one spot with 0.65 six percent of search
traffic that's about two-thirds of the
volume of searches that are gets now
granted it's a little bit of an apples
to oranges comparison when we look at
our vs. Python in this way because
python is a general-purpose programming
language however R and SAS I think is a
fair comparison because theyre both
predominantly used for data analytics
with academia in particular taking a lot
of interest in each of these two
languages so that's cool
but we obviously need to break that down
a lot further right now in mid 2019 so
pretty recently
birch works did a survey of various
analytics professionals and data
scientists and ask them about their
preferences between SAS r and python the
results are very interesting so this is
the six year trend in survey respondent
preference of SAS versus r versus python
and you'll notice that in 2014 and 2015
it was just a SAS versus R comparison
then in 2016
Python was added to the sir
and as I talked about in my other video
Python has skyrocketed in popularity
while our has fallen slightly meanwhile
sass though has fallen directly off a
cliff it had about the preference of 66%
of respondents in 2014 but in 2019 it's
all the way down at 29% so sass seems to
have lost a lot of popularity in the
last few years
then again over the exact same time
period data science has exploded in
popularity so let's break this down a
little bit by industry and by years of
experience and that should help us get a
clearer picture of where things are
today and where they're going this is a
breakdown of language preference by
industry it's from the same 2019 Birch
work survey and as you can see R and
Python beat or are tied with sass in
every single industry however
professionals in certain industries do
seem to prefer sass much more than they
do in others in particular in the
advertising and marketing sector 38% of
professionals prefer sass in the
financial services industry it's 35% and
then in healthcare and pharma its 33%
next if we look at years of experience
that's even more interesting now among
people with 11 years of experience or
more they still use and prefer sass at
very high numbers however among people
with less than 10 years experience or
people who are just college or grad
students virtually nobody is using sass
all these numbers are at 15% preference
or lower now this is all really
interesting I do think it's fair to
point out that everything I've shown you
so far is a percentage during a period
where data science and analytics jobs in
general have exploded so let's take a
look at the job market so when you look
at data science specific jobs and how
often these languages appear in their
descriptions it's a very similar picture
python appears and about double the
number of job descriptions as r does but
then R still has close
to double the number of jobs that SAS
does are seems to appear in about
fourteen thousand job listings while SAS
appears in somewhere around eight
thousand it's also down below other
technologies such as C C++ or C sharp
Hadoop tableau and spark so that's all
very interesting now there are a few big
takeaways here first of all if you're in
an industry like Big Pharma or big
finance SAS is still all over the place
and there's no way that you're going to
be able to avoid it however the gap in
SAS preference across experience levels
is extremely telling quite frankly the
new generation is not using SAS very
much now and there's not a lot of
incentive for them to start when jobs
out there don't require it as much as R
or Python so as the new generation
starts to become the new leaders they
become directors of analytics or chief
technology officers you could gradually
start to see SAS phased out of the
industries that it still proliferate so
it really begs the question how exactly
did we get here well for a long time
SAS virtually had a monopoly in the
analytics space and as our and Python as
well as the data science brand in
general really grew starting around 2014
suddenly SAS had a lot of very serious
competition to it I already mentioned
SAS is not free and in fact it can be
quite expensive so if you're a newer
company that's just getting your foot
off the ground in things like big data
analytics data science and you don't
have to use SAS based on any kind of
regulation
you're probably gonna pick R or Python
which are free any day of the week over
SAS I don't personally have a ton of
experience with SAS myself
I used it a little bit when I was back
in school also when I started my job in
pharma I had to start using it a little
bit more just because it's everywhere
here and on one level cess does have
some really nice qualities you can do
virtually any data manipulate
in it quite easily it's very easy to
write sequel code in it and it's very
easy to pick up and learn
however the visualizations are
incredibly subpar and inflexible
compared to our or even to Python SAS
also lags behind the open source
languages on advanced capabilities like
machine learning and deep learning just
because when your proprietary software
and not open-source you just don't have
that same level of agility so overall
what's my opinion well if you're
interested in government work or you
have interest in the financial or
advertising or pharmaceutical sectors
you're probably going to want to learn
SAS if you don't know it already in 2020
it's still everywhere and frankly you do
need to know it in order to stay
competitive if you're just starting out
in data science though if your domain
agnostic maybe you're interested in
startups
honestly SAS is not anywhere near my top
list of things that I would recommend
that you learn SAS is use has been on
the decline in the last few years and
with Oran Python being where they are
now and a whole new generation of future
leaders and analytics professionals are
not using it as much it's really
difficult for me to see that trend
reversing certainly if you're bored and
you've just mastered everything else or
if you do find it popping up in your
domain or industry a lot go ahead learn
it go for it but I honestly do think in
2020 for the vast majority of people
getting into data science and especially
with things like giulio really catching
on right now there's just a bigger bang
for your buck that you can get from
learning other things what do you think
do you agree with me do you disagree
do you love SAS do you hate it let me
know in the comments then I'll see you
all next time until then richard on data